beaucoup de phénomènes qui se dévoile à
nous ne sont en réalité que le reflet
d'une multitude d'événements complexes
qui se joue en arrière-plan et échappe à
notre perception naturel les
illusionnistes manis aussi avec talent
en détournant notre regard pour nous
cacher la vérité et nous donner
l'illusion de phénomènes impossible qui
n'a jamais rêvé de percer les secrets de
ses tours de magie qui émerveille les
petits et interroge les gros pour moi en
tant que scientifique je dois vous dire
que c'est presque obsessionnelle et que
comprendre ses tours de magie prend
souvent le pas sur l'émerveillement du
tout en lui même découvrir le secret de
ses illusions nécessite généralement de
changer de point de vue
pour découvrir ce qui nous était jusqu
alors invisible
je vous invite à ouvrir les yeux à
changer de perspective pour sortir de
votre zone de perception et découvrir
ainsi un monde invisible qui évolue
juste sous vos yeux dans nos parcs nos
jardins et nos forêts en quelque sorte à
voir l'invisible et tout ça pour
comprendre le monde qui nous entoure
si vous promener en forêt peut-être
avez-vous déjà observé d'étranges
structure à la surface des feuilles sur
les tiges ou sur les bourgeons parfois
plate parfois ronde parfois coloré
parfois poilus ses structures et leur
diversité fascine et interroge les
biologistes depuis des siècles ces
structures végétales ce ce que l'on
appelle des gal des sortes de
prolifération des cellules de la plante
un peu comme des tumeurs
segan
structure végétale n'apparaissent pas
comme ça par hasard elles sont la
conséquence de la présence à l'intérieur
du végétal de petits insectes qui
prennent littéralement le contrôle de la
machinerie cellulaire de la plante pour
créer de véritables nouveaux organes
avec parfois des structures complètement
extravagants comme sega le chevelu que
l'on peut observer sur les rosiers ou
sur les églantiers lorsque je dis que je
travaille sur ces insectes qui vivent
dans les végétaux qui en prennent le
contrôle qui les manipulent
on ne pose généralement la question mais
qu'est ce qui vous a amené à travailler
avec des insectes
alors j'aimerais vous répondre que déjà
tout petit je ramassais les coccinelles
que j'ai chez moi une collection
d'insectes rares ou que je passe mes
week-ends à quatre pattes à observer les
petites bêtes en réalité pas du tout si
je suis venu à travailler avec les
insectes c'est un peu par hasard au
cours de mes études
alors bien sûr avec le temps se prend
d'affection pour ces organismes et je
dois dire que les insectes présente des
particularités extraordinaire maintenant
ce qui est bien plus au coeur de mon
activité scientifique ce n'est pas tant
les insectes mais c'est finalement
comprendre le monde dévoiler les secrets
de son fonctionnement est révélée au
monde une réalité invisible
alors si ça c'est pas un objectif de vie
révélée au monde une réalité invisible
vous le disais le scientifique il a un
besoin de comprendre là pour comprendre
on se pose généralement deux grands
types de questions le pourquoi
à quoi ça sert et le comment comment ça
marche
moi je suis plutôt du style comment
alors pourquoi ces structures à quoi
elle sert pendant très longtemps on a
adopté le point de vue de la planque et
on a considéré que c'était un mécanisme
de défense qui permettait à la plante
d'emprisonner l'insecte et donc de
protéger la plante contre des dommages
trop important ce n'est qu'à partir du
moment où on a pris le point de vue de
l'insecte qu'on a réellement révélé la
fonction de ces structures
en réalité en créant ces structures
l'insecte va créer un environnement dans
lequel il va être protéger des
prédateurs des maladies des
perturbations environnement à la pluie
le vent mais également un environnement
nutritifs extrêmement favorable la
plante fournit donc le gîte et le
couvert
maintenant comprendre le comment
nécessite de déceler les mécanismes qui
vont aboutir à la production de ses
gammes et en sciences on a une manière
de répondre à ces questions qui consiste
à faire des comparaisons on peut par
exemple comparer une plante attaqué avec
une plante scène et on peut faire c'est
comparaison au niveau biochimiques au
niveau physiologique au niveau
morphologiques ou au niveau des gènes on
peut par exemple comparer les gènes qui
sont exprimés dans un bourgeon intact ou
dans un bourgeon attaqué par un insecte
qui va se transformer en gagnent
lorsque l'on fait ceci on se rend compte
que les jeunes qui sont impliqués dans
la production des gal ressemble de très
près aux gènes qui sont impliqués dans
la production des fruits et à y regarder
d'un peu plus près il est vrai que la
structure et la morphologie des gal
ressemble très fréquemment à la
morphologie des fruits sachant ceci
voyons donc si vous commencez à observer
le monde sous un angle différent si je
vous montre cette photo qui d'entre vous
pensent que ceci est un fruit lever la
main
alors je dois avouer que c'est pas le
fait qu'on voit le plus dans les
supermarchés ou sur les étalages mais
c'est fait effectivement un fruit mais
certaines gammes présente des structures
extrêmement similaires une petite chance
de vous rattraper si je vous montre
cette fille désormais qui d'entre vous
pensent que ceci est un fruit lever la
main à cette fois ci on a plus de monde
en fait il ya un peu un piège c'est à la
fois une gale est un fruit entre nous
appelons ça un galet fruits comme ça ce
sera plus simple
en réalité les fixes sont des petits
sacs charnue qui renferme une multitude
des milliers de petites fleurs celles ci
vont être fertiliser grâce à
l'intervention de petits insectes qui
vous rentrer à l'intérieur chargées de
pollen
ils vont donc fertiliser certaines
feuilles fleurs qui vont se développer
en fruits mais vont également pondre
dans d'autres fleurs et les larves vont
former des petites galles dont elles
vont se nourrir
lorsque vous mangez une fille vous
mentent j'ai donc une multitude de
petits fruits mais également une
multitude de bébés guette
alors je vous le disais découvrir
l'invisible c'est changer de perspective
c'est aussi saisir le moment opportun de
l'observation
l'automne est un moment privilégié pour
révéler la présence au sein du végétal
de petits insectes qui se développe en
créant des galeries on appelle ça des
insectes mineurs et qui là encore vont
prendre le contrôle de la plante et
manipuler le végétal il faut voir en
quelque sorte l'automne comme course
contre la montre les uns vont essayer de
récupérer l'essentiel des éléments
nutritifs qui sont dans les feuilles les
taux pied dans les racines pour les
réinvestir au printemps suivant et
former de nouvelles feuilles
c'est ce qui aboutit entre autres au
jaunissement des feuilles puis à la
chute des feuilles l'insecte de son côté
va devoir essayer de compléter son cycle
de développement avant la disparition de
toutes ses ressources nutritive donc
prendre le contrôle de la plante permet
à certains insectes de maintenir un
environnement nutritifs favorable de mer
lignières à finir leur cycle de
développement
c'est pourquoi ces petits insectes
arrive à maintenir des zones
complètement verte fonctionnel alors que
le reste de la flotte feuilles jaunies
en quelque sorte ils empêchent la
feuille de vieillir alors de là à dire
c'est le secret de la jeunesse éternelle
ça reste encore à démontrer ici encore
on peut se poser la question mais
comment ça marche
alors depuis plus de 50 ans à l'institut
de recherche la biologie de l'insecte
on s'interroge sur ces interactions
entre les plantes et les insectes
et puis depuis environ une dizaine
d'années dans mon groupe on s'intéresse
plus particulièrement à ces insectes qui
manipule le végétal alors là ça m'amène
à une deuxième question qu'on pose
généralement avec un air généralement un
peu perplexe
ça fait dix ans que tu travailles sur la
même chaîne
et ben oui ça fait dix ans que je
travaille sur la même cheville et je
dois vous dire qu'on est loin d'avoir
tout découvert toujours est il que même
principe
si on veut comprendre ici comment
l'insecte manipule le végétal pour créer
un environnement protégé des prédateurs
des perturbations environnementales et
le tout avec tout ce qu'il faut pour
manger on peut procéder à des
comparaisons on peut comparer par
exemple une feuille attaqué avec une
feuille scène on peut faire ça au niveau
de la feuille au niveau de la zone
spécifique aux troubles 1,7 lors si on
fait cette fois c'est comparaison non
par niveau des gènes et au niveau de la
chimie de la feuille
on peut alors se rendre compte que si
l'insecte est capable de créer et de
maintenir cette zone verte fonctionnel
c'est grâce à l'accumulation de composer
spécifique dans la zone où se trouve
l'un 7
ces composés ce sont des hormones
végétales et plus exactement des
cytokines
alors je vous le disais ce sont des
hormones végétales la question suivante
qui s'est posé à nous c'est s'il y a
plus de ces hormones dans la zone ostrom
l'insecte d'où vient-il
vous me direz facile ce sont des
hormones végétales c'est la plante qui
les produit alors c'était notre première
hypothèse effectivement mais après de
multiples études on s'est rendu compte
que non ce n'était pas la plante qui
produisait ces composés donc si c'est
pas la plante qui s
c'est forcément l'insecte ça ne peut
être que l'insecte
c'est là que je dois vous faire un
terrible love et cie je ne vous avais
pas tout dit et si finalement tout ceci
n'était que la partie émergée de
l'iceberg
et si finalement ce n'était pas de
l'insecte qui étaient à la manoeuvre
pour manipuler ce végétal en réalité
après de multiples études nous avons pu
démontrer que si l'insecte réussi ce
tour de passe-passe qui empêche la
feuille de vieillir c'est grâce à la
présence à l'intérieur même de l'insecte
de bactéries qui vivent à l'intérieur
des cellules de l'insecte des bactéries
symbiotiques alors pour tester cette
hypothèse un peu folle nous sommes
partis dans des expériences non moins
extravagante
nous avons décidé de nourrir les
insectes avec des antibiotiques
ceci nous permet d'obtenir d'un côté des
insectes avec des bactéries et de l'eau
des insectes sans bactéries et lorsque
l'on fait ceci on se rend compte qu en
absence de leur passage et invisible
les insectes sont incapables de
manipuler le végétal alors là ça a été
un moment important un ces moments rares
dans la vie d'un chercheur ou après de
multiples années de recherche
fruit du travail d'une équipe entière
on met le doigt sur les mécanismes d'un
phénomène jusqu alors il expliqué alors
ça vous parlera peut-être pas mais je me
souviens encore de l'émotion que nous
avons ressenti lorsque nous avons fait
cette découverte
on se sentait un peu comme des
explorateurs ayant découvert des
territoires inconnus
alors avant de tirer en quoi ceci est si
important lorsqu'on regarde d'un peu
plus près la plupart des insectes vivent
en association avec des micro organismes
des bactéries des virus des protozoaires
et ses passagers invisible jouent des
rôles importants dans la physiologie
parfois même dans le comportement de ces
insectes les insectes mais également de
nombreux autres organismes sont donc à
considérer non pas comme des entités
unique mais comme la juste apposition
d'un ensemble d'organismes qui vivent
ensemble en plus ou moins bonne harmonie
les développements technologiques de ces
dernières années nous avons permis des
avancées considérables dans
l'identification et la caractérisation
de cette communauté invisible qui est
hébergé par la plupart des organismes et
je suis persuadé que ceci nous permettra
des avancées considérables dans la
compréhension du monde qui nous entoure
les conséquences de cet assemblage
d'organismes de tous ces micro
organismes qui vivent au sein d orgue d
êtres vivants sont considérables nous
avons des implications en terme de santé
humaine en termes agronomique en termes
de conservation pour vous donner
quelques exemples je vous le disais la
plupart des insectes vivent avec des
micro organismes
c'est également le cas des plantes
certaines plantes cultivées notamment on
au niveau des racines des bactéries ou
des champignons qui vont leur permettre
d'assimiler mieux les éléments nutritifs
du sol et donc une meilleure croissance
si l'on comprend le rôle de ces micro
organismes
à l'heure où on essaye de développer une
agriculture écologiquement responsable
on peut finalement inoculé délibérément
ces micro organismes dans les cultures
et augmenter la productivité
et agricoles simplement en stimulant des
procédés naturels
un autre exemple peut-être un peu plus
proche de vous on sait aujourd'hui que
de nombreux micro organismes sont
responsables de pathologies ou de
dysfonctionnement majeur comme par
exemple résister ici encore comprendre
comment interviennent ces
micro-organismes pourrait permettre des
alternatives aux traitements
médicamenteux
aujourd'hui on fait des transplantations
entre patients de micro organismes qui
nous permette de résoudre une partie de
ces dysfonctionnements
enfin en termes de conservation on a des
écosystèmes spectaculaires comme par
exemple les récifs coralliens où il ya
des association étroite avec des algues
colorer les grandes perturbations telles
que le réchauffement des océans entraîne
la perte de ces algues et une
fragilisation des coraux qui finissent
par mourir c'est le blanchissement des
récifs coralliens
ici encore comprendre le rôle des
micro-organismes identifié peut-être
certains qui aurait une tolérance une
résistante plus importante aux
variations de température pourrait
peut-être permettre de préserver ces
écosystèmes si particulier et tous les
rôles qu'ils remplissent en termes de
nutrition en termes de protection des
zones côtières ou tout simplement en
termes touristiques la biodiversité
notre patrimoine naturel et donc à
concevoir désormais dans sa globalité
avec sa part visible mais également avec
sa part invisible et c'est par la
compréhension de ses passagers invisible
et de leurs fonctions dans les
écosystèmes que passe peut-être nos
espoirs de conservation et de
valorisation de notre patrimoine naturel
c'est un enjeu considérable c'est un
véritable défi pour les scientifiques
mais c'est également un devoir si nous
voulons développer une société en
harmonie
avec son environnement en préambule je
vous invitais à ouvrir les yeux sur le
monde qui nous entoure a changé de
perspective
j'espère que vous marcherez désormais
les yeux grands ouverts pour percevoir
cette part invisible de notre
environnement et je suis persuadé que
vous découvrirez les insectes et que
vous les regarderait désormais avec un
angle nouveau
en ayant conscience qu'ils hébergent en
leur sein toute une communauté invisible
merci beaucoup